all these people going I'd love I don't  get why Dana doesn't play with Bellator  and they do this crossover because they  don't need to if I'm Bellator and I'm  rising or these other organizations keep  doing this this is different than what  the UFC does don't try to compete with  UFC and just do the exact same thing UFC  does because a you don't have the Stars  B you don't have the roster C you don't  have the depth you know so it's like all  these other organizations are constantly  trying to just mimic what the UFC is  doing Do Your Own Thing Do Your Own  Thing don't be a cookie cutter copycat  of the UFC this is completely different  the fan base especially the hardcores  need to realize all you guys going the  UFC would never do this just shows  they're scared no no no why would the  UFC change anything they're making more  money than ever why would they put shine  towards another organization they have  nothing to do with